[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
normani showed her wild side at the mtv
video music awards on sunday the 25 year
old singer performed her hit single for
the first time and she did not
disappoint
[Music]
normani hit the stage for a steamy girl
on girl grind bringing out surprise
guest tiana taylor the singer was
strapped to a human-shaped board
featuring footholds on each side while
normani climbed up and straddled her
body for a sultry dance
[Music]
[Applause]
and if this wild performance seems
familiar it is normani took a page from
janet jackson's book who has been known
to do the same thing on tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
normani's performance paid homage to
other iconic artists like tlc the 25
year old singer's futuristic all silver
outfit was seemingly inspired by the
iconic girl group's music video no
scrubs
[Music]
another tribute normani's choreography
appeared to pull from the late singer
aaliyah's moves
[Music]
and normani's song wild side has a
similar sound to aaliyah's hit one in a
million
[Applause]
needless to say twitter went wild one
fan wrote the mix sounds so dreamy i
love it also the fact that she gave us
some of tlc janet and elia in one night
normani is too
good and another user praised the singer
writing normani referenced both aaliyah
and janet yeah she knows the performance
was highly anticipated by normani's fans
who use social media to advocate for the
pop star to be included on the list of
headlining performers and honor she
first took on in 2019. this is where
the biggest moments in pop culture
happen when cardi b tweeted out that she
wanted to see her perform at the 2021
awards show normani tweeted back i hope
so and they haven't booked me yet fans
then bombarded twitter with messages
using the hashtag let normani perform
obviously it worked for the singer as
she owned the vma stage
[Applause]
[Music]